Замахи на колаборантів, вибухи на залізниці, підриви мостів, знищення окупантів й інформаційна війна.
Це неповний список того, чим займають українські партизани на тимчасово окупованих територіях.
Згідно з даними американського Інституту дослідження війни, партизани - нині одні з рушіїв успішної боротьби
українців з російськими окупантами.
Завдяки партизанській діяльності росіяни не розгортають цивільні адміністрації
на окупованих територіях і відкладають референдуми.
Чинний в Україні Закон про основи національного спротиву передбачає три його складові.
Перша - це тероборона, яка має діяти на неокупованих територіях.
Друга - рух опору, а саме - підготовлені партизани з військовим досвідом, які готові чинити диверсії.
Третя - це громадянський, ненасильницький спротив.
Експерти особливо відзначають спротив на тимчасово окупованих РФ територіях не підготовлених партизанів,
а тих, хто став ними спонтанно.
На початках було не так багато учасників руху опору.
Але після того, як росіяни почали чинити свої репресії, почали вчиняти свавілля,
вже неможливо було проводити мирні мітинги і якось демонструвати свою прихильність до України -
значно збільшилася кількість людей, готових долучатися до руху опору.
Причому це абсолютно різні люди, і починаючи від такого низового рівня, там, де люди розклеюють листівки там,
де можуть, вчиняють акції громадянської непокори, інформаційні акції.
І до більш радикальних дій, коли просто-напросто відловлюють патрулі, знищують майно окупантів.
За словами Кузана, найчастіша допомога місцевих партизанів Збройним силам України - інформаційна.
Коли місцеві передають інформацію ледь не про кадровий склад окупантів,
завдяки чому ЗСУ знає, що відбувається на окупованих територіях.
Саме ненасильницькому опору навчає Центр національного спротиву.
На сайті проєкту десятки інструкцій, як чинити опір на тимчасово окупованих територіях.
Команда Центру спілкується зі ЗМІ в масках.
За їхніми словами, розкриття обличчя їхнього складу ставить під загрозу життя десятків партизанів, з якими вони співпрацюють.
В чому вважається спротив населення?
Українці на окупованих територіях не хочуть брати російських паспорт.
В Херсоні вже пропонують по 10 000 рублів тим, хто візьме паспорт - люди відмовляються тотально.
Росіяни вже роблять фейкові черги, але в них і це не виходить.
За словами речника Центру, спротив може проявлятися у відмові від користування рублем,
у відмові в співпраці і в знищенні даних про населення, аби їх не використали для штучних референдумів.
Навіть розклеювання листівок - потужний психологічний хід.
Коли російський військовий (він три місяці на чужій землі), він щодня бачить на стінах "Смерть ворогам", "Слава ЗСУ", "Слава Україні".
Коли він бачить листівки "Рускій солдат, йди за напрямком руського корабля", повірте, у нього морально психологічний стан
не дуже його мотивує оборонятися у разі контрнаступу й інших дій.
Особливо коли й наші партизани одночасно підривають певну техніку й колаборантів,
то ці військові в час Х складуть зброю і втечуть у бік Кримського півострова.
Допомогти контрнаступу - одна з основних цілей партизанської діяльності в тилу.
Американський професор Олександр Мотиль з березня досліджує партизанські рухи в Україні.
Мотиль зазначає, що в останні тижні диверсійні дії українців інтенсифікувалися не просто так.
Моє враження, що все більше подій відбуваються в останні три тижні.
Це справжні атаки на росіян, на українських колаборантів і на інфраструктуру.
І це все розгортається тоді, коли Україна продовжує успішний контрнаступ на півдні України.
І я допускаю, що це пов'язано - атаки Збройних сил і різноманітні атаки партизанів.
Попри те, що про партизанів здебільшого говорять у контексті півдня України,
найбільша операція, яка вразила професора Мотиля, відбулася на Луганщині.
У Кремінній, за словами очільника Луганської ОДА Сергія Гайдая, стався "витік газу" у мерії,
у результаті якого померли понад 10 колаборантів й окупантів.
Сергій Кузан з Українського центру безпеки і співпраці відзначає також Мелітополь,
в якому підірвали залізничні колії і кілька разів вчиняли напади на патрулі в комендантську годину.
Однак експерт наголошує, що про велику кількість спецоперацій в різних населених пунктах
буде відомо тільки після перемоги.
Олександр Мотиль зазначає, що український партизанський рух зараз успішно розгортається ще й тому,
що росіяни не можуть сконцентруватися на ньому.
Якби війна закінчилася завтра і ці території залишилися під контролем Росії,
я впевнений, росіяни би застосували ту ж тактику, яку вони мали у Західній Україні після Другої світової війни,
щоб знищити всі рухи.
Вони будуть безжальні, не будуть щадити цілі родини.
Однак зараз це важко зробити, тому що вони мають перейматися про фронтову лінію.
І все ж, представник Центру національного спротиву зазначає, що українцям на неокупованих територіях
важливо зараз не забувати про людей, які чинять опір в окупації.
Підтримувати цих людей, говорити про цих людей, писати цим людям, згадати, з ким ти спілкувався 10 років тому в інституті -
і, можливо, він з Бердянська - так давайте я напишу йому повідомлення в Телеграм чи в іншому месенджері…..
написати "Привіт! Я підтримую тебе! Я бачу, що ви робите - давайте!
Ви герої, тому що ви чините спротив".
Це міста-герої. Ось що потрібно.
Опитані DW експерти схильні вважати, що український партизанський рух витривалий
і може триматися ще багато місяців, а за необхідності й років - до повної перемоги України.